hey guys welcome to the second patreon q
a on this channel
where i'll be answering a bunch of
different questions you guys have sent
in
the next q a will be happening later
this month so if you want me to answer
your question in a video
then just head on over to patreon and
submit it there
the first question comes in from stephen
lopez who asks
how do you think the war arc is going to
end
i don't see that coming to an end any
time soon i know the arc has been going
on for a really long time at this point
pretty much the whole of 2020 so far
but in the mighty academia universe it's
only been like a couple of
hours at most i mean the heroes raided
the hospital and they raided the mansion
how long has that really been it's been
less than a day so
the war itself has really just begun i
don't really see the end in sight not
any end that i can predict anyway
i guess i can estimate that by the end
of the day
i reckon that shiguraki will somehow
kidnap deku because
his aim seems to be you know stealing
one for all and taking deku away to do
that
so i reckon shiguraki will succeed in
whatever he sets out to do
um also i believe that dabi you know
he's on his way to meet endeavour
uh well i mean he's not going there to
meet endeavor but he will obviously
endeavour's gonna be there as will shoto
so i reckon the debbie reveal will also
happen
um and ultimately i think this day will
end
with the villains going to tartarus
prison and breaking all for one out
and obviously along the way
gigantomachia will be destroying pretty
much
everything he can get his hands on but
yeah regarding the whole war
itself i can't tell you how that's gonna
end because it's really only just begun
next question comes in from chronos gw
and he says
what do you think happened at the forest
did the sleeping agent
fail or is it just taking time to set in
how did giganto get away
and where is the rest of the league are
the students in the forest okay
so there's two possibilities on what
happened in the forest
and it all depends on how safe hirokoshi
is playing things
my brain is telling me that the most
likely option is that the sleeping agent
just hasn't kicked in yet
and the more makia moves around the the
sooner it will kick in
so maybe he gets to the battlefield
where shigaraki is and then
gigantomachia collapses
maybe something like that could happen
um because i think momo did in fact say
that maki has to move around a bit for
the sleeping agent to work
that said until this is confirmed i just
have this nagging suspicion in my head
that the sleeping agent is not actually
a sleeping agent
if the traitor reveal is going to happen
this could be the time like
we know machia has somehow gotten past
all the heroes gotten past all the
students
and we have no idea what happened so
that leaves a gap in the story where
yeah there could be a traitor reveal
another thing i'd say is that the
anesthetic right that momo created
i think it was like two chapters in
total um where
they were just hyping it up as this
thing that could stop gigantomachia
so for it not to work in any way well
then what was the whole point of that
why was harakoshi hyping it up so much
clearly something's gonna happen whether
you know whether it's in favor of the
villains or the heroes
the the sleeping agent has to have some
effect otherwise that whole storyline
was just
oh sorry the whole plot point was just
for nothing
i reckon the league of villains are
still probably on his back
i know we couldn't see it in chapter 282
but i reckon they're still there
i don't think harikoshi would have left
them behind because you know like i said
it's a perfect opportunity
for debbie to come face to face with
endeavour and shoto so i reckon at the
very least
makia has got dabi on his back regarding
the final part of your question
are the students okay i'm sure the
students themselves are
you know in decent shape i don't think
anyone's died the heroes though
so majestic and fat gum and all those
other guys that were swooping in
those guys might not be in good shape
you know maybe some of them might have
died or been gravely injured
i think that's a possibility but if he's
going to kill a student
i don't think that will happen at this
moment trey cash says
i have a theory on how erased quirks can
be recovered
nato monimer could still copy overhauls
quirk even though overhaul can't use his
quirk since his hands are missing
if he could copy his quirk and practice
on killing and bringing mice back to
life
he could eventually use his quirk to
return lost hero's quirks
what are your thoughts so yeah it is
true that
monomer could still copy overhauls quirk
because unlike mirio
overhaul still technically has his quirk
factor even though his hands are
completely gone so yes
you are right in saying that however
there are a couple of problems with what
you said um
i think the first thing is that a quirk
is is literally part of someone's dna
like it's ingrained into them
just the same as anything else and yes i
know overhaul can manipulate matter
but in order to rearrange someone so
that their
dna is different fundamentally like
i think you need to have a very very
detailed knowledge of that person
and how their genetic makeup what it
looks like
if we compare it to moma for example she
can't create something that she doesn't
know how it works right she can't make a
rocket ship because she doesn't know how
to make a rocket ship
i think in the same way if monamer
copied overhauls quirk
he couldn't start giving people their
powers back because he doesn't know what
their dna looked like when they had
powers so
i don't think that works but it's a nice
idea though it's a nice
theory but i just don't think that could
ever happen the next question comes from
dark ghost
who says which two characters in my
academia whether they be alive
dead or in their prime would you like to
see fights
yeah this is an awesome question the
obvious one
is current sugaraki vs prime almighty
because karachikaraki is a beast he's
got
not only all the quirks of wolf one but
he's also got basically all my levels of
strength
not to mention super decay which cannot
be underestimated
so that versus all my in his prime well
that would be a really interesting thing
because
when baka girl was a kid he said you
know no matter what situation all might
is in
he's always a winner so i wouldn't know
how all might would beat shigeraki
in his current form he can't touch sugar
like he would normally touch a villain
because then he gets decayed most likely
so what does he do what's his strategy
detroit smash him into space you know
just detroit smash him into the moon
maybe something like from one punch man
or something like that but um
no i think that would be the most
interesting fight that we could see
stephen lopez says when do you think
midoriya is going to get his float quirk
and this is followed by chronos gw who
says when does dekulan float
will deku speak to nana shimura before
he is able to use it
similar to how deku got advice from all
funk
before using black whip further down the
line best
guess as to previous holders or the next
quirk that will be unlocked
um so yeah he will definitely speak to
nana because he's already spoken to two
previous users at this point
so it's only logical that when he
unlocks new quirks he speaks to the same
users in the way that he did to the guy
the black whip guy and then eventually
once he's met all the different users
you know they can meet up inside one for
all have a bit of a get together a
little round table
or something like that but uh but no
yeah he's definitely going to speak to
her
and um in terms of when float will be
coming
he only activated blackwhip in a
situation where he wanted to capture
someone
it was during the joint training arc he
wanted to capture monamar so black whip
took it upon itself to activate
in that same way when he's trying to
avoid the decay
then um potentially you know float might
get activated then
it's unlikely shigiraki will try and
decay deku because he wants to steal
deku's quirk
but you know he might try and decay
someone else and you know bakugou
perhaps
and dekugo tries to intervene and then
float activates
so i do think we will be seeing float um
definitely in the war arc
though if it will happen on this uh on
this day you know the day that i keep
referring to where everything's going
down
is is possible it's definitely possible
chronos then goes on to say
what did all might want to talk to stain
about
i think the thing that all might really
wanted to get from staying was
understanding why stain considered him
to be a true hero
because we all know stain had a very
confused view of who and who wasn't a
true hero
and in stayne's own words you know once
a hero takes
money in exchange for saving people they
aren't really a hero anymore
and this is something that stan's
followers also believe you know we've
heard spinner say this line
so whilst all my is indeed you know we
know he's a true hero
but you can't deny he's taken money just
like everyone else
he's been on the chat shows he's got all
the merchandise and for everyone who's
read vigilantes you'll know
all might has a massive building that is
his hero agency you know
big big corporate building like all
might was not poor guys he was making
money just like everyone else
probably way more than everyone else so
you know
by stain's own logic almighty himself
should not have been considered a true
hero
but he was so potentially almighty wants
to discover
why that is or might may have saved
stain when he was a kid
you know we don't know stain's full
backstory we know a little bit about it
because of vigilantes but we don't know
the full backstory
next question is considering the events
in 282
what is your updated guess to who if
anyone
loses their quirk if i remember
correctly tomorrow still has
two more bullets with him yeah it's
possible he has at least two bullets
with him
though it's possible maybe more and i
also don't think that shigaraki is going
to waste quite destroying bullets on
people who are irrelevant
so he's not going to throw one at manuel
he's not going to throw in a rock clock
he's definitely not going to throw them
at people like that because it's just a
waste
you know he could kill these people in
an instant if he wanted to so
yeah he's not going to be wasting them i
doubt it will also hit bakugo
he is so unbelievably popular that to
make bakago quirkless
would actually cause an outrage i reckon
many people would stop reading the
series
to me endeavour is the biggest
possibility of everyone who's currently
there
shigaraki doesn't like endeavor you know
these two are having a fight
endeavor gave him the vanishing fist
which um
let's just say it put sugaraki in a
really bad position really bad state
so shiki probably wants revenge and he
might get rid of endeavour's quirk
and also with dabby coming to the
battlefield when dabby arrives if
endeavour is bleeding and quirkless i
mean i'm sure debbie would love that
um especially because we saw back in the
pro hero arc debbie was willing to
attack endeavour when he was down
so if endeavour's quirkless dabby's
going to be over the moon
it's just ideal situation um so yeah
most likely i'd say endeavour the last
question for this video
is will harikoshi actually kill off a
student
in 1a now this is a very interesting
question
yes it is definitely possible um i was
thinking that harukoshi was making a lot
of bold decisions this arc you know
mirko was gravely injured hawks has most
likely lost his quirk
crust is dead you know these are top 10
heroes we're talking about
so he's not afraid to hurt big players
and it's also the natural consequence of
war because in any war
young people die whether they want to or
not you know
innocent people young people who enlist
that they die
it's just a fact so yeah some of the
classic students by the end of this
whole thing will not be with us anymore
but uh that's just the nature of the
beast you know when you're coming up
against
evil itself people are gonna people are
gonna die
but yeah guys that was everything from
me for this second q a
thank you guys on patreon for your
support and the next q a like i said it
will be happening
later this month in september so do be
sure to submit on patreon
if you want behind the scenes content
and also uh
your questions answered in these type of
videos my spoiler review for chapter 283
should be coming out tomorrow so until
then peace out